[Música]
ahora de la información económica quiere
directo américa edición nocturna por
ello me acompaña en el estudio mi
compañero jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido
la noticia económica del día gira en
torno a la compra de twitter por parte
de hilo mosca el hombre más rico del
mundo va a poder comprar su red social
favorita que él mismo ha denominado la
plaza digital del pueblo fue una
transacción que duró 11 días primero la
junta se mostró realce a la oferta no
solicitada pero todo cambió la semana
pasada cuando moss presentó un plan de
financiación que incluía a 12 bancos
entre ellos morgan stanley y cerró el
trato por 44 mil millones de dólares un
precio 38% por encima del cierre del
primero de abril el día antes de que
mouse dijera que tenía una participación
importante le preguntamos a andrés
moreno asesor financiero y analista
económico y bursátil sobre la
importancia de esa transacción para los
mercados y esto nos respondió ha sido
muy interesante este intercambio primero
porque el principio cuando avisó a la
oferta o consiguió un 9% inicial dijo
que era una inversión pasiva después fue
aumentando y queriendo quedarse con la
compañía
en la cual hubo una resistencia muy
importante de los accionistas diciendo
que no quería pero después fueron
evaluando hicieron cuanto a los
beneficios a largo plazo es interesante
entender que esas este tipo de
transacciones son normales en las
grandes empresas es normal que cambien
de dueños que las acciones suban
precisamente por ese intercambio y pues
vendrán un nuevos aires nuevas políticas
sobre todo en temas de divulgación de
información y de no ser muy restrictivos
con información que hay por parte de
twitter es muy interesante el movimiento
y eso pues nos enseñaba muchos en las
bolsas latinoamericanas en las
colombianas de entender el beneficio que
tiene este tipo de cambios para el
precio los accionistas y no solamente
minoritarios sino también mayoritarios
valentina y es que tras la compra para
los usuarios de la red social se
avecinan cambios importantes que el
mismo mons anunció cómo poder evitar los
tweets o que el algoritmo sea de código
abierto conversamos antes con jose con
experto en redes sociales y director de
iu lv y esto dijo sobre los probables
cambios que ahora tras la compra
a ver distintos cambios muy importantes
dentro de la plataforma pero el primero
sería un tema de liberación de lo que
podríamos llamar la desinformación
twitter es una plataforma que es el
termómetro social de distintos países y
ha sido
desprestigiar constantemente por el tema
de la desinformación y los trolls los
bots entonces en primera instancia se ve
una intención clara a mitigar a
controlar este problema en segunda
instancia la búsqueda de un modelo de
negocio hasta hoy es una plataforma
donde el tema de la rentabilidad le ha
afectado entonces seguramente vamos a
ver cambios en esa línea posiblemente
suscripción o funcionalidades como la
edición en un segundo caso y tercero
erradicar todo lo que en el concepto de
y un mos que es la censura por ejemplo
las banderitas debajo de una cuenta así
como ésta cuenta pertenece un gobierno o
por ejemplo restarle restablecer la
cuenta de donald trump como acciones que
vamos a ver inmediatamente con este
cambio de directiva de la plataforma
jorge 58 por ciento de los votos logró
emanuel macrón el domingo y fue
reelegido presidente de francia cuáles
son los principales retos económicos a
los que se enfrenta el mandatario son
muchos pero los principales se reducen
en el costo de la vida la deuda pública
y los salarios estos son los principales
para el segundo mandato de macrón 144
años más claro se convirtió ayer en el
tercer presidente de reelecto pero entre
sus principales retos está recuperar el
poder adquisitivo de los franceses
afectados por una inflación galopante
así como realizar una reforma al sistema
de pensiones una encuesta reciente de
ipsos afirma que el 65 por ciento de los
ciudadanos les preocupan los precios de
la energía seguido por la inflación y
las pensiones la inflación se disparó en
francia a un 4,5 por ciento en marzo
respecto al mismo mes de 2001 motivada
principalmente por los precios de la
energía y de la alimentación macrón
prometió impulsar una ley del poder
adquisitivo que aumentaría las pensiones
de jubilación a corto plazo así como un
nuevo bono libre de impuestos para los
empleados y un cheque de alimentos
macrón también debe enfrentar una enorme
deuda pública que se disparó por la
pandemia y se ubicó en 112,9 por ciento
en 2021 así como los retos que supone la
guerra en ucrania para toda europa pero
principalmente
parís jorge pues a ustedes muchas
gracias por esta ampliación en economía
lo invito a que continúe con nosotros
que ya vamos a nuestro espacio directo
con nuestro corresponsal en eeuu
[Música]